[Music]
i-55 on your friday morning what's
driving you crazy a
mystery bridge at the 95
and grand teton let's go
centennial bowling
so when we talk about the mystery bridge
we got an email from viewer patrick who
wrote
we live just off osablanc and grand
teton six years ago we were told a
bridge was in the plans over the 95 to
grand teton on the east side of the
freeway
is this ever going to happen it was a
reason many families bought here
well patrick i checked with tony ilya
from the nevada department of
transportation he said
well that's going to be a future city of
las vegas project so
i checked in with the city of las vegas
and the city's public works department
says
over the past few years we've had to
coordinate this project with the
ndot folks as well as homeowner
associations on each side of the 95
21 million dollars in federal money
should be available in the spring of
2021.
we're hopeful to be granted a notice to
proceed to the bidding phase shortly
thereafter
if they say the design's complete
they're basically just waiting for the
federal money
the bridge will take 18 months to build
and
may be completed in late 2022 or early
2023
patrick tony and lb public works thanks
for riding in buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com